What we've been talking about so far in the course are human universals,
what everybody shares.
So we've been talking about language,
about rationality,
about perception,
about the emotions,
about universals of development.
And we've been talking about what people share.
But honestly what a lot of us are very interested in is why we're different.
Um,
and the nature of these differences and the explanation for them.
And that's what will turn to today.
So first we'll discuss how are people different,
different theories about what makes you different in a psychological way from
the person sitting next to you.
And then we'll review different theories about why people are different.
And,
um,
this is the class which is going to bother the most people.
It's not dualism,
it's not evolution.
It's this because the scientific findings on human psychological differences are
too many of us.
Shocking and unbelievable.
Um,
and I will just try to persuade you to take them seriously.
Okay.
So how are people different?
Well,
there's all sorts of ways.
Um,
your sexual identity,
it is at the core of your being for almost all of us,
whether you're male or female,
how we refer to you in language,
what Pronoun we use indexed on how we are on your,
on how,
whether you're male or female.
Um,
and related to that though in perfectly your sexual orientation who you're
attracted to,
the question of why some of us think of ourselves as males and others as
females.
And the question of why some of us would ideally want to have sex with males,
others were females,
others were both.
And in a few others who have harder to define desires is such a good question
that we're going to talk about it after spring break.
Um,
while all the sexual desire has been spent and you could focus on a scientific
discussion of this,
not that I recommend you do that on spring break.
Um,
how happy are you?
This is also such a good topic is going to get his own class.
I,
the very last class of the semester is devoted to happiness.
And the question of what makes people happy,
um,
what makes people unhappy?
And what makes people differ in their happiness.
If I asked you to rank how happy you are from a scale of one to 10,
the numbers would differ across this room.
And there's different theories as to why,
um,
your success and failure in life.
This is somewhat interesting because you can study this in more or less
objective ways.
We don't have to ask people.
We can look at your relationships,
how they begin,
how they end your job satisfaction.
We can look at your criminal records.
Some of you are going to see time,
most will not.
Um,
some of you will get into a little troubles all through your life.
Some of you already have seen the inside of a police station possibly align up.
Others couldn't go near such a thing.
What,
what determines that?
And at the root of all,
human differences
are two main factors.
And so I want to talk about the two main interesting factors.
Um,
one is personality,
the other's intelligence.
And this is what,
these are the differences I'll talk about today.
First from the standpoint of how do we characterize them,
how do we explain them?
And then from the standpoint of why these differences exist in the first place.
I'm
one way to characterize personality is in terms of people style,
with dealing with,
in dealing with the world and particularly their style with dealing in dealing
with other people.
So you take a simple character,
you know of,
um,
and you could talk about that person's personality,
but talk about in terms of being impulsive,
irresponsible,
sometimes lazy,
goodhearted,
um,
you could compare that person's personality with other people's personality,
such as my colleague who gave a talk last class.
He's wonderful.
He's responsible and reliable and very kind,
um,
and and different from homer.
And so there's differences,
a difference in personality.
Now when we talk about personality,
we're talking about something else as well.
We're talking about a stable trait across situations in time.
So if all of a sudden the person next to you kind of smacks you in the head,
you might be angry,
but we wouldn't call that personality because that's something that,
that's the result of a situation.
We'd all feel that way in that situation.
It's personality.
If you walk around all the time angry,
there'd be a stable trait to be sending you carry around with you.
Um,
and that's what we mean by personality.
Now,
how do we scientifically characterized differences in personality?
And it's a deep question,
has been a lot of attempts to do so.
Um,
any assessment has any good assessment has to satisfy two conditions and these
are terms which are going to show up all over psychological research,
but it's particularly relevant for this sort of measure.
One is reliability.
Reliability means there is not measurement error.
And one crude way to think about reliability is a test is reliable.
If test the same person at different times and you get the same results.
My bathroom scale is reliable.
If whenever I stand on it,
it gives me more or less the same number.
It's not reliable if it's off by 10 pounds in the course of a day.
Um,
similarly,
if I give you a personality tests now and it says that you're anxious and
defensive while and then give it to you tomorrow and it says you're calm and
open minded,
it's not a reliable test.
So reliable is something you could trust over time.
Validity is something different.
Validity is,
um,
is that your test measures what it's supposed to measure.
So validity means it's sort of a good test.
Forget about how reliable it is,
does it tap what you're interested in?
So for example,
suppose I determine your intelligence by the date of your birth.
I figured out what day you were born.
And I have a theory that from that predicts how smart you are.
That's my own intelligence test.
The date of your birth,
maybe,
um,
people born in January or the dumbest people born in December or the smartest is
that I was born on Christmas Eve.
Um,
is that,
is that a reliable test?
Yes.
It's a wonderfully reliable test.
I'll test you today.
I'll text you tomorrow.
I'll test your next year.
I'll text you the day you die.
I'll get the same Iq score.
Is it a valid test?
It's a joke.
It's absolutely not a valid test.
It has nothing to do with intelligence.
But you notice these are two different things.
Somebody can be reliable but not valid.
Um,
and something can be valid.
And not reliable.
Now there are no shortage of personality tests.
You could get them all over the place,
um,
including on the web.
So I took one recently,
I've took,
I took a,
which superhero are you?
And it's a series of questions.
I determining what superhero are you are,
you could take this yourself if you want to.
Um,
the same web page by the way offers you a test and whether you're hot or not,
and we'll discuss that later.
And when I did this,
it told me I was Batman.
Um,
and you are dark love gadgets.
And I vowed to help innocent not suffer the pain you have endured.
Now the honest now,
to be honest though,
it's neither reliable nor valid.
When I first did the test,
I came up as the incredible hulk.
Um,
I then change my answers a bit and was wonder woman.
And finally,
finally at a frustration,
I carefully tailored my answers so I will be Batman.
But the fact that I can do that well raises questions about,
um,
about both the reliability of this measure and it's validity.
Um,
here's an example,
a real world example.
This is in black and white form a version of the roar shock test,
the Rorschach inkblot test.
How many people have heard of the Rorschach test?
Okay.
Is there anybody here who is actually in any sort of situation taken a Rorschach
test?
Some people scattered room have taken them.
Um,
it was originally used only for a psychiatric cases,
but then became extremely common.
Um,
about 80% of clinical psychologists claim to use it.
And most graduate programs,
I'm in American Psychological Association,
uh,
who are accredited.
I teach it a Catholic seminaries and use it for people who want to join the
seminary.
Um,
it was invented by a guy named Herman,
a roar shock.
Um,
he devoted his entire life to the inkblot test,
his nickname when he was a teenager.
I am not kidding you was inkblot.
Um,
and the idea is by looking at these inkblots and then seeing what somebody says,
you get great insights into the nature of their personality,
into,
um,
what they are.
Anybody want to cry?
Come on.
Yes.
What do you see
that's together?
Two people holding hands pressed together.
Very good.
Anybody have a different reading?
Yes and back?
Yes.
Dancing bears.
Okay,
good.
Good.
Okay.
I got to write her name down.
Report you to help certain no.
Death dancing.
They're dancing bears.
Very good.
Anybody else?
One other,
yes man.
A man and a ski mask.
Well,
it turns out that there are right answers and wrong answers to the Rorschach
test.
Um,
according to the test,
and this is from a real Rorschach test.
It is important to see the blog as to human figures.
Usually females are clowns.
Good work over there.
If you don't,
it's seen as a sign.
Do you have problems relating to people?
Um,
if you want to go for a caveman,
France or butterfly or vagina,
that's also okay.
Um,
now
the Rorschach test is transcendently useless.
It has been.
It has been studied and explored and it is as useless as,
as throwing dice.
It is as useless as tea leaves.
Um,
nonetheless,
people love it and it's used all over the place.
Um,
it is used,
for example,
in child custody cases.
If,
um,
if you have broken up with your partner and you guys are quarreling over who
gets to keep the kids,
uh,
you might find yourself in a shrink's office looking at this.
And in fact,
this is why they end up on the web.
There are services,
there are people have been kind enough to put on the web these inkblots
including the right answers to them,
but they are worthless as psychological measures.
Can we do better?
Well,
we probably can.
Um,
Gordon Owl court did a study where he went through the dictionary and took all
of the traits that he believed to be related to personality.
Um,
and he got 18,000 of them.
But what was interesting was they weren't necessarily independent traits.
So the traits like friendly,
socio bubble,
welcoming,
warm hearted seem to all tap the same thing.
So Catell and many others try to narrow it down,
try to ask the question in how many ways are peoples personalities different
from one another?
How many parameters of difference do you need?
How,
how many numbers can I give you that was narrow you in and say what personality
you are?
Um,
one approach was from um,
icing who claimed they were just too,
you going to be somewhere on a scale of introverted,
extroverted and somewhere on a scale of neurotic and stable.
And since there's basically two types of traits with two settings reach,
there are basically four types of people.
Later on he added another trait trait a which he described as psychotic CISM
versus non psychotic autism.
But crudely meant whether you're aggressive,
are empathetic,
and then you have three traits with two settings,
each giving you a types of people.
Um,
later on Cattell dropped it down into 16 factors.
So these 16 personality factors are 16 ways people would differ.
And so if I ask you to describe your roommate along these 16 dimensions,
you should be able to do so.
More recently people have come to the conclusion that two or three is too few,
but 16 might be too many.
And there's a psychological consensus,
um,
on what's been known as the big five.
And the big five personality factors,
um,
are these,
and what this means is when we talk about each other
and use adjectives,
the claim is we could do so in thousands of different ways,
but deep down we're talking about one of these five dimensions.
This means that when a psychological test measure something about somebody,
about our personality,
if it's a good test,
is measuring one of these five things.
And it means that as people interacting with one another and the world,
these are the five things that we're interested in.
Um,
so one of them is neurotic versus stable.
is somebody sort of nutty and a and worrying or are they calm?
Extrovert versus introvert?
Um,
open to experience versus close to experience.
Agreeable,
which is a courteous,
friendly versus non agreeable,
rude,
selfish and conscientious versus not conscientious,
careful versus careless,
reliable versus undependable.
Uh,
a good way to think about these things is in terms of of the word ocean,
the first letter captures openness,
conscientiousness,
extroversion,
agreeableness and neuroticism.
And the claim is those are a four to five fundamental ways in which people
differ from one another.
Well,
why should we believe this?
Why should we take this theory seriously?
Well,
there's actually some evidence for it.
Um,
it seems to have some reliability in that it's stable
over time.
So if you test people over years,
if I test your personality now on a five traits and test you five years from
now,
it will not have changed much.
And once you passed the age of 30,
it's very stable indeed.
If you think about your parents and then give mum and dad a mental test and
where they stand on each of the five traits,
10 years from now,
mum and dad will still be there.
Um,
it also seems to get agreement across multiple observers.
So if I ask for each of the five traits,
if I asked your roommate what he or she thinks of you,
did they ask you're a professor,
what he or she thinks of you and your mom,
what he or she thinks of you Howard,
back to gender,
how would,
um,
they match up.
They tend to overlap a lot.
You walk around and you leave and you,
your personality leaves a trail in the minds of people around you.
And his trail is characterized in terms of these five dimensions.
Um,
finally it seems to be predict real world behavior.
It just didn't have anything to do,
have to real world.
You wouldn't be very happy calling it a valid,
you wouldn't take it seriously as a desk,
but it does.
So it's so conscientious.
And how you score in a conscientious and scale,
um,
relates to how faithful you are to your spouse.
Uh,
how openness open you are,
are,
are a psychological personality.
Tests relates to how likely you are to change your job.
Um,
extroverts look people in the eye more and have more sexual partners cause
they're extroverts.
So these are real scales.
Um,
the Batman Hawk wonder woman doesn't correspond to anything in the real world,
but where are you stand in each of these five dimensions does seem to capture
it.
Um,
as an example of the agreement,
by the way,
uh,
somebody did a study of several of the characters on the television show.
The Simpsons because they want it to find characters,
which everybody knew.
And they had 13 subjects judge,
uh,
the symptom characters on each of the five dimensions.
Um,
this is an openness,
neuroticism,
conscientiousness and extraversion.
Um,
and he,
they found considerable agreement.
And this isn't actually what I've covered up is to agreeableness.
So for those of you who've never seen a television show,
this is all going to be confusing,
but those of you who have,
can you guess which characters would be particularly agreeable?
Anybody?
Yes.
Yeah.
Flanders.
Um,
you are right.
The most agreeable people are Flanders and march who would be not so agreeable.
Cresty is actually Cressey.
Is it complicated case?
Um,
but,
but Mr. Burns,
but also
where is he?
Oh,
he's not was Nelson.
Where's Nelson?
Anyway,
there's Nelson.
Um,
you get strong consensus that Ned,
Ned Flanders and Marge Simpson are highly agreeable people.
Six Point two seven and 5.46.
Well,
Mr. Burns and Nelson are very low.
Nelson's the little kid that when trouble happens,
he goes,
ha ha.
And that's,
that's a psychological sign for low agreeability.
Okay.
That's all I want to say at this point about personality and how we measure it.
And again,
we're going to get back to it later when we talk about differences in
personality.
Now I want to deal with the second big difference.
The second big difference is intelligence.
Now how do you define intelligence?
There is no easy definition,
light personality.
It's kind of difficult to get your fingers on what we're talking about here.
Uh,
in one survey they asked a thousand experts to define intelligence and some
answers showed up over and over again.
So just about everybody said intelligence involves abstract reasoning,
problem solving,
and the capacity to acquire knowledge.
That's at the core of being smart.
Other people mentioned things like memory,
mental speed,
language,
math,
mental speed.
Again,
knowledge and creativity.
Also as hallmarks for intelligence.
And again,
it might be difficult to define it,
but you have a gut feeling about what it is.
So,
you know,
homer is,
is actually,
and this is part of the show,
is actually of limited intelligence.
Um,
my colleague is a very high intelligence,
wonderful fellow.
Um,
but,
but he's probably not as smart as that guy who's like really,
really smart.
And this Guy Ralph Whigham,
it's particularly stupid.
And so you have a range and,
and,
and it's important to figure out how to characterize it.
This is what research does,
but there's a gut feeling that there's some people who are smart and other
people who are very smart and some people who are dumb and others who are very
dumb.
What you want to do,
I do from a scientific standpoint is characterize this in a more robust and
interesting fashion.
And The textbook has a nice review of the history of attempts to define and
measure intelligence.
But there's just a couple of ideas I want to focus on.
One is an idea developed by,
by a Spearman,
which is,
there's two types of intelligence.
Um,
there is g and there's s s is your ability on specific tests.
So if there's 10 tests that you're given as part of an Iq,
an Iq test,
10 sub tests,
you'll get a different score in each of the sub tests will be a math test and a
reading test.
And a spatial test and you'll get different scores.
G refers to a general intelligence and the general intelligence is something you
bring to each of the tests in common.
So this is diagrammed here you have these six tests.
For each of them there is an ass and then above that there is a g.
Now,
GE is a very important notion.
The term g is used by psychologists a lot even in casual conversation,
you know,
people say,
so what do you think of him?
And he has high g and what you mean is he's a smart guy.
Why do you need g where you wouldn't need,
Gee,
if your performance on each of these tests had nothing to do with each other.
If the test were genuinely separate,
there'd be no general intelligence.
But what people find over and over again is that when it comes to explaining
people's performance on multiple intellectual tasks,
there's two things going on.
There's how good their is.
They are on a specific task.
But then there's also a sort of general correlation that people bring to the
tasks.
And I could express this with an athletic analogy.
Imagine I'm running a gym and we have all of these different athletic tests.
So we have a running test,
we have a basketball shooting test,
a swimming test,
fencing list of 10 of them.
Now each of you go through each of the tests and then you'll each get 10 scores.
But what we'll discover is that the scores are not independent of one another.
People who are good at one athletic thing tend to be good at another.
Um,
if there's somebody who's really good at running and swimming,
odds are they're probably pretty good at climbing.
Um,
and the same thing holds for Iq,
which is above and beyond how good people are at specific things.
There seems to be a factor as to how well they are in general.
And this factor is known as g.
Now
there's a,
again,
an extensive history of modern intelligence tests.
Uh,
and what's really interesting is the tests now where you need to know,
but the modern test,
the Wechsler test for both adults and children is how they're scored.
The way they are scored is that a hundred is average.
So it's just automatic.
Whatever to averages is a hundred is as if I did the midterm graded the midterm
computer to average gave everybody who got to average a hundred said your
score's a hundred.
It's just the average.
It works on a normal curve.
And what this means is that it works so that the majority 68% get between 85 and
115 under Iq tests.
The vast majority,
95% get between 70 and 130.
Uh,
if you are say above 145 Iq,
which I imagine some people in the room are,
you belong to a 0.13% of the population.
That's the way Iq tests work.
Now this is about Iq tests.
We can now ask about their reliability and their validity.
What did they mean?
Well this is turned out to be a matter of extreme debate.
This just reiterates what I just said.
Um,
a lot of the debate was spawned by the book by Hurnsteen and Marie about called
the bell curve and in a bell curve these authors made the argument that Iq
matters immensely for everyday life and that people's status in society,
like how rich they are and how successful they are follows from their Iq as
measured in standard Iq tests.
Now this book made a lot of claims and,
and it's probably before many of you,
many of your time,
um,
but spawn huge controversy.
And as a result of this controversy,
some interesting papers came out.
One response to the Hurnsteen and Murray book was by the American Psychological
Association,
which put together a group of 50 leading researchers and intelligence to write a
report on what they thought about intelligence,
what they thought about,
does Iq matter,
how does Iq relate to intelligence?
How does,
um,
what's,
what's the different,
wider people different than intelligence,
wider different human groups,
different intelligence and so on.
Um,
at the same time there was also another group of Iq research and researchers,
not quite the same as the first group got together and wrote another report.
And if you're interested in this,
the links to the reports are on a power point slide.
Well what did they conclude?
The conclusions were slightly different,
but here's the broad consensus by the experts,
um,
regarding the importance of Iq tests and the claim is Iq is strongly related
more so probably more so than any other single measurable human trait to many
important educational,
occupational,
economic and social outcomes.
In some cases the correlation is very strong,
such as um,
success in school and success in military training.
In other cases it's moderate but robust such as social competence.
And in other cases it's smaller,
but consistent law abiding this and they can include whatever Iq tests measure
it is of great practical and social importance.
So IQ matters.
Um,
more particularly Iq matters for social achievement,
for prestigious positions and for Andre job performance and other work related
variables.
If I know your Iq score,
I know something about you that matters.
It's not irrelevant.
Just as if I know your score on a personality test at a big five,
I would know something about you that as you would tell me,
something interesting about you in the real world.
On the other hand,
there's a lot of controversy about why this connection exists.
Um,
so to some extent people have worried that the effectiveness of Iq is a self
fulfilling prophecy.
And here's why.
If society takes Iq tests important,
seriously,
they become important.
So it's true that your Iq is very related to your success in getting into a good
school like Yale.
But the reason for this in large extent is because to get to Yale they give you
an Iq test,
the sat.
So,
um,
same for graduate school,
there's a GRE which is yet another Iq tests.
So to some extent it's a self fulfilling prophecy.
Um,
I could make,
society could choose to make how tall you are.
Extremely important for educational success.
They could say nobody under six feet tall gets into Yale.
And then some psych professor would stand up and say,
of course,
height is profoundly related to educational accomplishment.
And it would be because people made it so,
so to some extent is society that draws highly and Iq tests,
um,
regarding promotion and educational,
educational achievement and military status and so on.
Um,
it's just going to follow that Iq then becomes important at the same time.
However,
the role of Iq is pretty clearly not entirely a social construction.
Um,
there's some evidence that your Iq score you're relates to intelligence and an
interesting sense including domains like mental speed,
um,
and uh,
memory span.
So you're,
you're,
you're scoring Iq tests for instance,
is to some extent related to how fast you could think and,
uh,
your memory abilities.
Okay.
Now I want to shift to the second half of the class and talk about why.
So we talked about two differences.
One in person at one personality,
one intelligence.
I want to talk about why people defer,
but before I do,
uh,
do people have any questions?
Yes.
Test,
test works.
It's a very strong self presentation.
Yes.
But how did you deal with that?
It's a good question.
The question is this young man took,
um,
took,
I just took a personality test.
He was,
he was accepted into Slitherin,
which is a Hogwarts reference.
I'm,
I'm hip to that.
Um,
and,
and uh,
but the question is a good one.
Um,
um,
you're,
you're a,
you're a clever man,
um,
hygiene,
and you want it to be in slitherin.
How do we know he didn't work the test?
I mean,
you know,
you,
you're going to get these personality tests all the time and you know,
pretty nice to test if you're applying for a business.
And one of the test is I like to steal from my bosses.
Oh,
I don't think so.
No,
that's a little Iq test right there.
Um,
so the question is how do you avoid that problem?
the test constructors have done so in certain clever ways.
Um,
for instance,
there are often catch questions designed to catch a liar.
Um,
some of these questions posed very unrealistic phenomena.
So you might have a question in there saying,
um,
uh,
I have never done anything I am ashamed of.
Now some people will say,
yes,
that's true of me,
but they tend to be lawyers.
And so unrealistic questions tend to catch liars.
Also you get to the same question asked in different ways across the hundred
items and they could use the correlations to figure these things out.
I mean,
again,
the proof is sort of in the pudding.
The reliability and validity of a test,
um,
is determined in part by just how well it does at predicting future performance
on a desk and your real world performance and a test that is easily fool,
easily tricked by smart people wouldn't survive long as a personality test.
So we know that we know the test you got is a pretty good test because it seems
to work for most people.
Yes,
that's success is more related to emotional like you rather than to it.
It's a good question.
The question was about emotional Iq,
which is Sunday.
I'm actually going to touch upon a little bit later in the course,
but people have talked about different forms of intelligence and emotional
intelligence.
Social intelligence is,
um,
is a,
can arguably a candidate for success across different domains.
Um,
the evidence for its predictive power is not as strong as for regular Iq tests.
So you might be right,
it might turn out to be a much better predictor,
but one is not clear that we know that yet.
I'm Peter Salovey's actually done some very interesting research on us and it's
continuing work along those lines.
The second thing is emotional intelligence actually related to good old
fashioned intelligence.
They kind of pulled together a lot.
So it's not entirely separate.
But that's a good point.
And I'd like to return to it a little bit later on in the course.
Yes.
One
better than another test of what makes NSA to you with analogies works that sat.
Good question.
How do you determine when to get a good test is,
and again,
it's a real art going through the details of how to do that,
but the broad answers involve reliability and validity.
It's a good test.
If I test you today and I test you tomorrow,
I get the same score.
It's a really good test.
If your score on that test predicts your grades are,
if it's a personality test predicts um,
how many girlfriends you have,
our predicts whether people think you're a nice guy so you have to see both the
replicability of the test over time but also its relationship to real world
phenomena and that's important.
Again,
why do we know the Batman wonder woman hoke test is a bad one?
Well,
one answer is because what,
what I,
how I score on that test isn't that tell you anything about me.
It's not going to relate to my grades is not going to relate to how well I'm
liked.
How do we know to sat is useful?
Well it actually corresponds with other things like grapes.
Yes and back.
Absolutely.
The question is when I'm talking I'm a personality,
I'm defining it in terms of sending which is stable over time.
And your question,
which is a good one,
how do we know it's stable over time?
Candidate change and the answer is yeah,
a lot of personality does change over time.
A personality tests you give to a 10 year old will relate,
but not so strongly with that individual when he's 50.
On the other hand,
we know that that the psychological claim that there exists such a thing as
personality and it is stable over time is supported by the fact that if you're
an extrovert now,
you're likely to be an extrovert 20 years from now,
not perfectly.
So you're right,
you could change,
you could become an introvert,
you can become more of an extrovert.
But where do you stand now is significantly related to where you'll be in the
future and that justifies talking about it as a stable trait.
Same with Iq.
Your Iq might change,
it might go up,
it might go down,
but it won't go up and go down that much.
And this is why it makes sense to talk about intelligence as a more or less
stable trait.
Okay.
Why are we different?
Well,
you're different
because of two things.
Uh,
your genes and your environment,
your nature and your nurture,
your heredity and your experience.
This doesn't say anything.
This is just defining the question.
Um,
but the question of the role of genes and the role of environment,
uh,
in,
in explaining human differences is an interesting one.
And it could be explored in different ways.
But before talking about it,
I have to clear up a common misconception.
I'm going to talk about the effects of jeans and I'm going to talk about
heredity,
but I want to be clear.
I am talking about the role of genes and also the role of environment in
explaining human differences,
not in explaining human characteristics.
So the distinction is we're interested in amount of variation due to genetic
differences,
not to proportion of an individual's trait that's due to genes.
So for instance,
you could pull these apart.
The question of,
um,
when we ask what's the role of genes,
what's the rule of heredity in how tall people are?
The question is not asking for you what is the role of your genes and
determining how tall you are.
It's not clear.
It's even a sensible question.
The question is there is a height difference between you and me and him and her.
How do we explain that difference?
And I could illustrate why heredity doesn't mean the same thing as the
contribution of the genes.
Um,
height is reasonably heritable,
meaning,
um,
the differences between people in the population and how tall they are is due in
large part,
not entirely,
but in large part to their jeans.
What about the number of legs people have?
Well,
the number of legs people have from zero one or two is actually not very
heritable at all because almost everybody has two legs and people will have
fewer than two legs typically have lost one or both legs in an accident.
It's not due to their genes.
So of course,
whether or not you have legs is a very genetic matter.
But the differences in number of legs is,
is not usually genetics.
And so heredity is a claim about differences,
not a claim about the origin of any specific trait.
Well now we,
that's what heredity,
which is genetic.
Now we could talk about environment and we could break up environment into two
sorts of environment.
One is shared environment and shared environment is the extent to which the
differences are caused by things by phenomena that's people raised in the same
household share.
So if one,
suppose some of you are neurotic
and suppose we want to say it.
Part of that's due to your environment.
Well suppose you're neurotic because you have lousy parents
that would be part of your shared environment because presumably siblings raised
in the same household would have the same lousy parents.
This is contrasted with non shared environment which is everything else.
Suppose I think you're neurotic because when you were five years old somebody
threw a snowball at unit,
bounced off of your head.
That's non shared environment.
Suppose you're neurotic because you won the lottery when you were 21 and all the
money messed you up.
That'd be non shared environment.
So what you have here is heredity,
shared environment and non shared environment and this equals one that's
everything.
Non shared environment is a sort of garbage can category that includes
everything that's not heredity and not shared environment.
Suppose you think you're an erotic because aliens from the planet,
Pluto are Zapping your brain.
Suppose you're right.
Well I would be non shared environment because they're presumably not
necessarily zapping your siblings brings everything else is non shared
environment.
It becomes interesting to ask
for all these differences,
the physical differences like height,
but psychological differences like um,
personality and intelligence.
How do we parcel it out and to what's genetic and what's environmental?
Um,
this proves to be really difficult in the real world because it's in the real
world.
It's hard to pull apart genes and environment.
So,
um,
so,
so you and me will have different personalities.
Why?
Well,
we were raised by different parents and we have different genes and we can't
tell my,
my brother and me,
my chair,
all sorts of things in common.
But we had the same parents and the same genes,
50% of the same genes.
So how do we tell what's causing us to be alike?
So to do,
to pull these things apart,
you need to be clever.
You need to use the tools of behavioral genetics.
Um,
and to use these tools,
you have to exploit certain regularities about genes and about environment.
One thing is this,
some people are clones.
Mano is,
I got a twins are genetic duplicates.
They share 100% of the same genes.
That's kind of interesting.
Dies I got twins are not clones.
They share 50,
50.
They're just like regular siblings and adopted siblings have no special genetic
overlap.
That's 0% above and beyond randomness.
Those three groups then become rather interesting,
particularly when we keep in mind that by definition two people raised in the
same house by the same parents have a 100% the same shared environment.
So now we can start to answer these questions.
Suppose you find that monozygotic twins are much more similar than dies.
I got it.
Twins.
Well,
I would suggest that there's a large role of genes in those traits that you're
interested in.
It would not cinched a matter because there were other factors at work.
For instance,
Mano is,
I got a twins look more alike than dies.
I got twins and maybe they have different than Deb.
More similar environments because of this similarity in appearance.
Armando is,
I got it.
Twins just as similar as dies.
I got a twins.
If so then it would show that though that all of that extra overlap and jeans
doesn't really matter and so it was suggested a low role of heredity are adopted
children highly similar to their brothers and sisters.
If so dinner is a high role of shared environment.
Suppose the bloom children,
um,
and there's seven of them all have an Iq of 104 and we adopted three kids and
then at the end of the day those three kids each have an Iq of 104 that would
suggest that.
And we do this over and over again across different families that would suggest
that there's something about the bloom family being raised by me that gives you
an Iq of 104 on the other hand,
if the Iq of the adopted kids had no relationship to those of the biological
bloom children,
it was suggested.
Being raised by me has no effects really in your Iq is sort of separate.
A separate,
a second,
a final contrast,
which is the thing that psychologists love is identical twins reared apart.
That's the gold standard because you'd have these people who are clones but
they're raised in different families.
Um,
and to the extent that there are similar,
this suggest it's a similarity of their jeans.
Um,
and in fact one of the,
one of the most surprising findings in behavioral genetics,
the caption here is separated at birth.
The Malheur for twins meet accidentally ended at a patent office with the same
device.
Um,
one of the hugely surprising findings from behavioral genetics is how alike
identical twins reared apart are they seem to have similar attitudes to the
death penalty to religion and to modern music.
There they have similar rates of behavior in crime,
gambling and divorce.
They often have been founded,
have bizarre similarities.
They meet after being separated at birth and they meet at age 30.
And then it turns out they both get into a lot of trouble because they pretend
to sneeze and elevators.
Um,
there was one,
one pair of twins studied by,
um,
behavioral geneticists were known as the giggle twins because they were both
would always giggle.
They burst into giggles at every moment even though it couldn't be environment
because they weren't raised together.
Um,
more objective Lee,
the brain scans of identical twins reared apart show that their brains are so
similar.
In many cases you can't tell who's brain is who I get tell your brain from my
brain,
from a brain scan and my,
my brother's brain from my brain,
from a brain scan.
But if I were to have an identical twin,
it would be very difficult to tell who's brain is,
who's even if we had no environment in common.
So this leads to two surprising findings of behavioral genetics.
This is the first one.
There's high heritability for almost everything.
Um,
for intelligence,
for personality,
for how happy you are for how religious you are for your political orientation
there,
for your sexual orientation,
there was high heritability.
There's a high effect of genes for just about everything.
Now that's actually not the controversial thing I'm going to tell you.
But before getting to the more controversial thing,
um,
I want to raise another issue,
which often gets discussed and has a good treatment in a textbook.
Um,
this suggests that individual differences within this,
within a group have genetic causes.
Does that mean that group differences are largely the result of genetic causes?
So we know that there are clear differences in Iq scores among American racial
groups,
between whites and Asians,
African Americans,
Ashkenazi Jews,
there's clear and reliable Iq differences as well as some other differences.
Now,
to some extent these groups are partially socially constructed.
Um,
and what this means is that whether or not you fall into,
into a group,
um,
is not entirely determined by your genetic makeup is often determined by social
decisions.
So whether or not you count as a Jew for instance,
um,
depends not entirely on genetic factors,
but also on factors such as whether you're reform or Orthodox and whether you,
so whether you would,
uh,
accept that the child of a Jewish man and a non Jewish woman is Jewish.
Um,
similarly,
categories like African American and white and Asian often overlap broad genetic
categories.
And they don't make fully coherent genetic sense.
At the same time though,
there's plainly some genetic differences across human groups and um,
say with regard to vulnerability to disease,
Ashkenazi Jews for instance,
are vulnerable to taste sacks.
And the fact that you would have this sort of genetic vulnerability suggests
that there's some sort of reality to these groups.
So you have to ask the question now.
To what extent does the high heritability in individuals mean that there has to
be a heritable explanation across groups?
And the answer is not at all.
I'm not saying that this means that there is no genetic explanation for human
group differences.
All I'm saying is the question of the phenomena of Wolf ingroup genetic
differences does not mean that there's a cross group genetic,
sorry between group genetic differences.
Um,
there was a nice example by Richard Lewington,
the Iba,
the geneticists where he imagines two plots of,
um,
what are you some sort of a wheat?
Yeah,
two plots of land and each one has a set of seeds and oh no,
they're over here.
No there anyway,
one of them,
you fertilize a lot.
The other one you fertilize a little now with in each plot,
how much the seed grows is actually largely determined by the genetics of the
seed.
And so you'd find high heritability for growth in the seats.
But the difference between groups has no genetic cause at all.
It's caused by which groups you fertilize more than others.
Here's another way to do to,
to do the logic.
Suppose from the middle down here you guys,
I hate you,
I really hate all of you and I like you.
So I make up two midterms.
You probably didn't notice,
but there are two midterms.
This Mitchard was fiercely hard,
savagely hard.
It took many of you till the end,
the class to do it.
This midterm was,
you know,
which is bigger,
a dog,
an elephant.
Because I like you and I want you all to succeed now.
So you have two different groups,
you guys and you guys with any age group,
some people are going to do better than others.
The explanation for that might actually have to do if your genes,
it may have to do for your environment how much you've studied with all sorts of
reasons for that.
Well if any each group,
some of you will do better in a heart test and then others on a heart test,
some better on easy test then then then than others and easy test.
But how do we explain the group difference?
Why has nothing to do with genes?
The group difference if I do you will do much worse than you has to do with
exams.
I give my point again is that there is a logical difference between a within
group difference within this half of the class and a difference between groups
within between this group and this group.
What do we know about,
so that just shows they're not the same thing,
but what's the fact of the matter?
What do we know about human differences,
uh,
between different human groups?
Again,
the textbook has a good discussion of this,
but um,
I'm going to give two reasons from the textbook that at least screw differences
or at least to a large extent due to environmental and not genetic causes.
One is that the difference is we find an Iq seem to correspond better to
socially defined groups.
Then genetically defined groups.
They seem to correspond to groups defined in terms of how people treat you and
how people think about you as opposed to your DNA.
And to extend that turns out to be true.
That would mean that that a genetic explanation is not reasonable for those
differences.
A second factor is that we know I Q can differ radically without any genetic
differences at all.
And the most dramatic evidence of that is the Flynn effect.
The Flynn effect is one of the freakier findings.
The Flynn effect is the finding that people have been getting smarter.
You are much smarter on average than your parents.
Um,
if,
and the Iq test hide that,
here's why they hide that they hide that because they always make a hundred the
average.
So you come home and say,
Dad,
dad,
I just did an Iq test.
I got 120 and your fathers could work,
son,
I got 122 when I was your age,
Bro.
What neither of you acknowledge is your test was a much harder as people got
better.
They had to make the test harder and harder.
And this is plotted by the Flynn effect.
Um,
one of these lines is,
um,
one of these lines is an American one is Dutch.
I don't know which is which.
But the gist of it is that,
um,
that somebody who would have that if you in 1980 would take the 1950 test,
your average person in 1980 which score 120 on the 1950 tests with this means is
you take your,
your person who's average now and push them back through time,
20 years,
30 years,
um,
he would do much better than average.
Nobody knows why people are getting smarter.
Um,
and there's different theories of this
and in fact,
well wait,
Gcu reading response.
But,
but what this illustrates is that Eicu can change dramatically over the span of
a few decades without any corresponding genetic change.
And
that leaves open to possibility.
In fact,
maybe the likelihood that the difference is we find in human groups,
existing human groups are caused by the same environmental effects that have led
to the Flynn effect.
Okay.
This is not the surprise in claim though.
The high heritability for almost everything.
This is the surprise and claim.
Almost everything that's not genetic is due to non shared environment.
The behavioral genetic analyses,
um,
suggests that
MMM,
shared environment counts for little or nothing.
When it comes to personality or intelligence,
then an adopted child is no more similar to his siblings then he or she is to a
stranger.
To put it in a different way,
the Iq correlation,
you genetically unrelated adults who are raised in the same family is about
zero.
Suppose the bloom family all has an Iq of 104 and we adopt a kid.
What will this kids we adopted as a baby.
We raised him to be a 20 year old.
What's his Iq answer?
We have no idea because the Iq of the bloom family who are unrelated to him has
no effect at all.
Now if you think about the implications of it,
it becomes controversial.
Um,
and Newsweek I think caught the big issue when,
when they put in their title the question,
do parents matter?
And the question and the issue is parents are shared environment to say shared
environment does not affect your intelligence or your personality.
MMM.
Suggest that that how your parents raised you.
It does not affect your gene,
your,
your intelligence or your personality.
This isn't to say your parents didn't have a big effect,
um,
on your,
on your intelligence and personality.
Your parents had a huge effect on your intelligence in your personality around
0.5.
Actually they had this affected the moment of conception.
From then on end,
they played very little role in shaping you what you are.
The case for this which generated a cover came up in a controversial book by
Judith Paris called the nurturer assumption,
um,
which has a very long subtitle.
Why parents turn white children turn out the way they do.
Parents matter less than you think.
And peers matter more.
Um,
Judith Harris has had an intellectual and an interesting history.
she was kicked out of graduate school at Harvard,
um,
and told that she wouldn't amount to much.
The person who wrote the letter saying that she was not going to amount to much
was the department chair George Miller in 1997.
She wanted a George Miller award for her astounding accomplishments.
Um,
and when she wrote the book,
She took as a starting point,
her point of disagreement,
a famous poem by the poet Philip Larkin.
And many of you have probably heard us DePaul and goes like this.
They fuck you up.
Your mom and dad.
They may not mean to,
but they do.
They feel you have the false they had and add some extra just for you.
Um,
the last line of the poem,
the last bit of the poem ends,
man,
hands on misery to man.
It deepens like a coastal shelf.
Get out as early as you can and don't have any kids yourself.
It's beautiful.
Um,
Harris wrote a rebuttal.
How sharper than a serpent's tooth to hear your child make such a fuss.
It isn't fair.
It's not the truth.
He's fucked up.
Yes,
but not by us.
Okay?
Just to show that academic debates never end.
Um,
uh,
British psychoanalyst named Oliver.
Jane's James Outraged by Judith Harris's book.
The nurture assumption wrote another book in response called they fuck you up.
Um,
now
how do you tell your grandparents I wrote a book.
What's it called?
Can't tell you.
Um,
anyway,
um,
look,
if you're paying attention,
this has to sound wrong.
You must be thinking.
Of course there must be an effective shared environment.
Of course,
parents have an effect after all good kids have good parents.
There is no doubt at all that this is true.
There's a high correlation in parent and child for everything.
If your parents read a lot and there's a lot of books in your house,
you will become a reader.
Um,
if your parents are religious,
you will be religious.
If you're,
if you're raised by Bonnie and Clyde,
you will be a young thug.
Uh,
if your parents are poor,
you are likely to be poor.
If your parents are brilliant,
you are likely to be brilliant.
No doubt at all.
It is extremely robust correlation.
But the problem is this correlation.
It could be explained in different ways.
Everybody thinks it's because parents do something that affects their kids.
Your parents are bookish,
they read to their kids so their kids become bookish.
Um,
but another possibility,
which we know is true,
that almost always parents share their jeans with their kids.
Another possibility is it's the parents who are affecting,
sorry,
it's a child is affecting the parents,
not vice versa.
And to illustrate this,
um,
these different possibilities.
I want to tell you a little bit about a study and I really find this a
fascinating study that was reported last year.
Um,
and it was a study shown that suggested it.
Family meals help teens avoid smoking alcohol,
drugs and involve a phone questionnaire when he phoned up teenagers and their
parents that said,
a teenager,
do you do a lot of drugs?
Uh,
yes.
Do you have a dinner?
If your parents know and they take it off and then they ask other people and
they find that the,
the kids who are the good kids have meals with their parents suggesting this
headline.
I like this study because I have read,
I must have read in my career a thousand studies and this is the worst study
ever done in the history of science.
Um,
and,
and it's almost,
we could devote,
we could devote a week to discussing what's wrong with this study,
let's just,
but,
but here's the idea.
It is possible that they are right.
It is actually possible and there's no,
I have no evidence against it that having meals with your kids makes them into
good drug free,
non promiscuous non-drinking kids.
Of course.
It's equally possible.
It's the other way around.
If little Johnny is kind of is out there smoking pot and,
and cavorting with prostitutes and,
and,
and stuff like that,
he's not going to come home for a family meal.
It's the other way around.
Well,
if he's a good kid,
he might be more likely to have a family meal.
So the direction it might actually be,
not family meals,
make good kids,
but writ rather good kids stick around the house.
They have nothing better to do and have meals with mum and dad.
Another possibility is
there's good families and bad family's.
A good family is likely to have drug free kids and a family meal.
A bad family is likely of stone kids and no family meal.
So there may be,
there's an effect of the parents that had nothing to do with the family meal.
Here's the even weirder part.
They didn't factor out age.
So think about this.
Their sample included children ranging from 12 to 17.
Well,
let me tell you something about 12 year olds.
12 year olds don't do,
is a lot of drugs and likely to eat with their family.
17 year olds are stoned all the time and they don't eat with their family.
Um,
I've just be gone on this study.
Uh,
but the point is when you hear something like,
so now take something which you may be more likely to believe,
maybe you will either having parents who read to their kids that's good for
their kids.
Well maybe it is,
but most of these criticisms apply to that study to a bookish kid is more likely
to get his parents to read to them.
A good family.
Parents who are good parents in general are more likely to do all sorts of good
things that our kids and have good kids besides take another case to the so
called cycle of violence.
Yes,
it's true.
Parents who smack their kids tend to have statistically more violent kids,
but maybe the causality goes the other way around.
Maybe if you have a kid who's a troublemaker,
you're more likely to smack them maybe,
which seems to be entirely likely.
The propensity for violence is to some extent heritable and so even if the,
if the kid was not raised by the smacking parents,
whatever properties of that parent caused him,
led to the violence got inherited by the kid.
Now again,
this doesn't going to sit right for you.
And I've had,
I put this down because last year when I gave this talk,
people ran up to me and told me this.
They said,
look,
I know my mum dad had a huge role in my life.
That's why I'm so happy and successful.
Then other people said,
that's why I'm so miserable and screwed up.
But either way,
blame it on mom and dad or thank mum and dad.
And you might think,
you know,
when you become famous,
you stand up and you get your awards.
Maybe you'll thank you mum and dad.
When you go to your therapist and explain why you're so screwed up,
maybe you'll blamed.
He never took root my baseball game.
Well maybe,
maybe,
but you don't know.
We adopted.
If you weren't adopted,
you can't even begin to have the conversation about how your parents messed you
up.
Because if you're a lot like your parents,
you might be a lot like your parents.
Did you share their genes?
Of course you resemble your parents.
Um,
moreover,
how do you figure out which is the cause in which is the fact no mom's smack me
a lot.
And that's why I turned out to be such a rotten person.
Or maybe she smacked you cause you were rotten.
I mean,
no,
I don't want to get personal,
but it's very difficult to pull these things apart.
I'm a final point on this
one.
One response to Harris's book is this,
look,
even if this is true,
you shouldn't let this get out because if parents don't molar children's
personalities,
maybe why should they treat their kids nicely?
And you might be wondering is you might be thinking,
well gee,
if you don't have any effect on how your kids turn out,
um,
why be nice to them.
But there are,
you might want to be nice to them because you love them.
You might want to be nice to them because you want them to be happy.
You might want to be nice to them because you want to have good relationships
with them.
And I have a little bit more,
but I'm going to skip it and I'm going to move right to your reading response,
which is very,
very simple,
easy to,
easy to answer,
easy to grave.
Explain the Flynn effect.
It's a toughy.
So just explain that.
Um,
okay.
Have a wonderful spring break and I'll see you when you get back.